decidido sonriente solo tiene una idea
en mente organizar nuevas elecciones
legislativas
querías advirtió a la presidenta griega
que no formaría Un gobierno de coalición
tras sus buenos resultados en las
elecciones del domingo
creo que no se dan las condiciones para
la formación de un gobierno con el
actual parlamento
les devuelvo mi mandato para que
celebremos nuevas elecciones lo antes
posible
la decisión viene motivada por una nueva
ley electoral que entra en vigor el mes
que viene un sistema proporciona
reforzado que puede dar hasta 50 escaños
extra al partido líder el domingo la
derecha conservadora de kiriacos ganó
las elecciones por un amplio margen con
el 40.8% de los votos pero se quedó a
las puertas de la mayoría absoluta ya
que obtuvo 146 escaños de los 151 que
necesitaba en el parlamento
Esperamos que Grecia esté mejor en el
futuro porque lo que mixto takis no tuvo
tiempo de hacer en su primer mandato de
cuatro años lo puede hacer ahora Aunque
solo cumpla la mitad de sus promesas
todo irá bien
en cuanto a la izquierda se ha hundido
el partido sirisa de Alexis cipra solo
obtuvo el 20% de los votos frente al
31.5% de Hace cuatro años
es una gran derrota para la democracia
las instituciones y la sociedad civil
antes de anunciar nuevas elecciones la
presidenta griega tiene primero que dar
mandato a los otros cuatro partidos
representados en el nuevo parlamento es
poco probable que alguno de ellos
consiga formar un gobierno en ese caso
habría que nombrar a un juez de alto
Rango como Primer Ministro interino